let's hear from some people in the
audience we now take calls via discord
it just works better it works better
than the things we used to do you can
find the discord at davidpakman.com
discord
let's go
first
to kevin from grand rapids presumably is
that michigan kevin
kevin from grand rapids you are on the
air
and last chance for kevin from grand
rapids kevin please
hello
you're on the air
you can hear me
now i can
oh thank you hey david great to have a
call uh first first-time caller thank
you um
yeah i'm calling uh
i don't really i kind of not starting
off on a super topical one because i
know the elections happened last night
and um you know that's kind of a lot to
talk about but i had a question um kind
of a general one would you um agree that
it seems like people on the right are a
lot more
um organized as one these days
in a sense that like they seem to agree
and like
work towards goals at least
slightly or mostly better than people on
the left do and what we could do to
maybe
come together and start to have some of
that presence that people on the right
seem to be getting one up us honest with
like i don't know i consider myself a
self a democratic socialist but i know
that there's a lot of people like uh
people are a little more liberal than i
am that might like we might disagree on
certain things i don't need to get into
the specific specifics of it but i just
i kind of think that
it seems like the left is a little less
cohesive and together
and a little bit more prone to like
nitpicking things i think you're right
kevin i've got a few videos on this um
and indeed i do think that there are
some on the left who sometimes uh let
the perfect become the enemy of the good
it's definitely an important issue and
one i've talked about but kevin i i'm
gonna let you go because that smoke
detector that you got to deal with that
okay my friend so
that happened last night i gotta get a
nine volt battery exactly yep all right
thank you kev very good we've got a lot
happening there and i'm gonna let him
get to it let's go next to isaiah from
arkansas isaiah you are on the air
hi david can you hear me yes i
can um well i have a question but uh
first i'm gonna kind of follow up with
what kevin said
um in
there's definitely an issue
with democrats just being terrible at
campaigning effectively that was kind of
my conclusion from
virginia
and new jersey yeah
and in the state of arkansas where you
know we have like five democrats elected
in the entire state anywhere
there is just so much incompetence
and so much of
anybody working
um so i don't want to take too long but
to
kind of say quickly
i was in a i was in a group i'm in
college i was in a group that was um
for like collecting like a young
democrats group
and i said that based on
how
disorganized the party is right now
we should be focusing on
um voting in the in the
republican primaries to keep out the
extremists because in arkansas you can
you have to pick which primary you vote
in right and i got kicked out of that
group
for as they said spreading republican
propaganda
so like if a basic thing like that of
strategy they're kicking out people
how do you expect to accomplish anything
sure of course that's the total thing
well um voting in democrat in republican
primaries when states allow you to vote
in either as a way to keep out the worst
candidate is a much discussed strategy
that has been talked about for a while i
think it's certainly a very interesting
one i think you're absolutely right that
part of what went wrong in virginia is
uh
that republicans are at a structural
advantage it's much easier to motivate
people to vote based on anger and fear
in virginia a lot of it was about
education and critical race theory and
fear and anger are just better
motivators to get people to engage with
the system and that's something that the
right uses significantly in this country
so i i think your analysis is exactly
right
and in arkansas i might be wrong about
this but i believe you have to either
vote in the republican or the democrat
you can't vote in both in the primary
yeah i think that that's the case in uh
that's i believe that's the case in
every state you can't vote in both
primaries yeah we have
the the fact of the matter is as it
stands in 2022 the election is in march
whoever wins the republican primaries in
in the office pretty much is going to
win in november and we have i think a
character i don't know if you're
familiar with them but i think you'll be
more familiar with them in the future
have you heard of jason or rapert no
he is a real lunatic
state senator we have that's running for
lieutenant governor
and
anyone listening just read the wikipedia
article on them kind of speaks for
itself but i don't want to take up too
much of your time but my question is for
someone like me living in
arkansas i i think
obviously i'm
kind of moderate left
you if you want to say i think the most
effective way
to actually change
the political demographics of the state
is or do you think it's just
better to just get out all together
that's it's your call as to whether you
want to get out or not it wouldn't be
illegitimate to get out if you decide
that you just want to improve your
circumstances immediately rather than
work to improve everybody's
in your state but get in find local
races find candidates that are that are
doing the right things as far as you're
concerned um and get get involved in
those campaigns is the best advice i can
give all right my friend i'm going to
move on because i've got a lot of people
waiting to chat
one of our sponsors is kami koto making
elegant high-end beautiful japanese
steel kitchen knives using traditional
techniques from honshu japan i've been a
big fan of japanese kitchen knives for a
long time they have some great
advantages when you look closely at a
kamikoto knife you see the quality of
the iron work they only use japanese
steel every knife comes in a perfect
heavy duty ash wood box makes storage
really easy it looks great in your
kitchen or drawer the balance of the
knives is just amazing i've been using
them for everything every knife comes
with a lifetime guarantee on their
website you can see the complete list of
chefs at michelin star restaurants who
use kamikoto and through this
partnership they're doing with us
kamikoto is giving you fifty dollars off
on top of their other special offers
just go to
camikoto.com
pacman and use the code pacman for fifty
dollars off the link is down below